[Applause]
the silver trophy to the golden knights
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my God
this one
[Applause]
oh my God
in their sixth National Hockey League
season the Vegas golden knights have won
the Stanley Cup
[Applause]
the captain Mark stone with a hat trick
in a series clincher
Jack eichel never played a postseason
game
[Applause]
prior to this season he's going to be
able to process it now and know he's a
Stanley Cup champion and
when you think about them missing the
playoffs last year and then
finding a way to make it this year and
then
win the cup
how many people will certainly look at
Jack eichel differently now
what is what a playoff by Sergey
Bobrovsky he was just flat out awesome
not a huge reason why the Florida
Panthers
got to the Stanley Cup Final
Brandon Montour had a terrific
postseason with eight goals
became a dad during the Cup final
[Applause]
one of the greatest traditions in sports
the handshake line
following each and every playoff series
the goaltenders for brovsky and Hill
123 block shots in this series by the
Vegas golden knights
they had 87.
in the last three
not only the great goaltending from
Aiden Hill but
the ability to sell out
they've done it all year
[Applause]